Asta is back baby and Tabata just
confirmed the truth God killer Asta is
literally a glitch in The Matrix the
only person capable of bringing down a
God Like Lucius and the real reason for
asta's incredible godly power is
directly related to the wizard King
Julius and the time devil asteroth don't
believe me just stick around until the
end of the video because this will blow
your mind you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our black lower content and you
want us to keep it going leave a quick
like and comment right now it takes you
like a second but it helps me out a lot
with the YouTube algorithm and of course
if you watch my videos but you still
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications subscribing on
YouTube is completely free but it's a
great way of supporting the channel
directly finally this video will of
course contain Black Clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned as we know the
final battle inside the Clover Kingdom
capital has been raging for quite a
while Lucius and his paladins have been
facing off against Yami and the other
magic Knight captains plus you know Noel
meadowlawnam and many others even though
some of the world's strongest Mages are
fighting against him Lucius has been
swelling the ranks of his paladins by
Reviving overpowered Mages who died
years ago like Morgan and Aussie a Silva
the battle has been extremely intense
and we've seen some incredible moments
with you know Yami Meadow Leona and of
course with Noel facing off against her
long dead mother and okay Jack I'll give
a shout out to Jack too but there Still
Remains one glaring absence on the
battlefield that absence is of course
hasta himself who is still stuck all the
way on another continent so far away
that even conventional spatial magic
cannot reach him back in chapter 360 we
were once again reminded that Asta is
extremely important important to this
final battle in his own inner monologue
Lucius concludes that the current
reality of the world is defying all of
his many predictions for how things were
supposed to go a lot of events and
scenarios are not unfolding as Lucius
had been expecting them to and the
common factor in all of them seems to be
Asta himself hasta is like a glitch in
The Matrix someone who isn't influenced
by lucius's time magic and someone who
remains a wild card in all of this and
not only is he himself a wild card but
by influencing the world and the people
around him he is also driving all of
them to reach levels of power that
Lucius couldn't have predicted Asta is a
big problem for Lucius he is a crack in
lucius's bulletproof master plan and
that crack appears to be growing and
spreading the latest chapter starts off
with Lucius lying dead on the ground
after a massive attack from yuno left
him essentially cut him too and yes
Lucius really is dead here so it's
technically not the manga equivalent of
clickbait although it's still kind of
clickbait just as yuno says I win Lucius
appears behind him and attacks him yet
again yuno is stunned because he knows
that him killing Lucius was not an
illusion that was the real body of
Lucius and yuno really did kill it yuno
is right that really was his real body
but so is this second one Lucius reminds
everyone that he possesses soul body
Blood and Bone magic all at once and
this allows him to literally clone
himself he could create not one by
multiple perfect clones of himself and
even if one of the bodies is killed the
other bodies will just carry on as usual
so even though asta's influence has been
messing with lucius's prediction
abilities and even though he is facing
scenarios that he was unable to
anticipate he is still confident
confident even if he is faced with
events that he cannot anticipate and
even if these events lead to his death
he still has backup bodies ready to
continue his sacred mission who knows he
might have even hidden some clones away
in the middle of nowhere where no one
will be able to find him even if every
single clone who is on the battlefield
now ends up getting destroyed but on the
other hand he may not even need those
hidden clones because he has at least a
dozen cones on the battlefield right now
and with how much the Mages of the
Clover Kingdom have struggled with even
one Lucius it's hard to imagine that
they would stand a chance against like
12 of them Lucius acknowledges that yuno
was a strong opponent but the odds that
yuno and the others are facing are just
impossible Lucius considers himself to
be a literal God and no matter how
strong a magic Knight becomes there is
still a world of difference between even
the strongest magic Knight captain in
history and an actual God when they see
all those lucious clones appear many of
the magic Knights begin to despair and
lose hope because their chances of
success appear to be just about zero at
this point however our girl Noel refuses
to quit and she implores the others to
follow her lead because there's still
hope the key to finding that hope lies
in the witch's Forest where the rest of
the black Bulls are currently located
led by Vanessa they have come to see the
one person who can help them locate Asta
and bring him back to the Clover Kingdom
in time that person is none other than
the mysterious and Powerful witch Queen
yo I was honestly really glad to see the
witch Queen finally return to the story
she first appeared way back in chapter
82 but then she effectively disappeared
from the story for a very long time
because of how clearly powerful she was
and how mysterious and interesting of a
figure she is in the Black Clover world
I was really hoping that she would make
a comeback and that we would learn more
about her and her powers eventually so
yeah I'm really glad to see that now in
the final Ark and during the final
battle the witch Queen has returned and
I mean it also doesn't hurt that she's
totally a MILF but let's move on the
black Bulls ask the witch Queen for help
in finding Asta but she already foresaw
that they were coming she confirms that
Asta is indeed alive and that he is in a
distant foreign land the black Bulls who
up to this point weren't sure that Asta
was still alive are very happy to hear
this news but even though there's good
news there's also bad news Asta is
simply too far away to just travel back
within a reasonable time frame at least
in terms of travel by conventional means
luckily for the black Bulls the coral
peacock Captain Dorothy unsworth who
just happens to be an overpowered witch
herself is also there inside the witch's
Forest along with the witch Queen
Dorothy knows that in order to defeat
Lucius they need to bring Asta back as
soon as possible as the one whose future
cannot be seen by Lucius Asta is
everyone's best hope for taking down
such an absolutely broken god-like
villain and Dorothy believes that if the
three most powerful witches of all time
work together they can bring Asta back
by the three most powerful witches she
means herself the witch Queen and best
girl Vanessa this is certainly a special
moment because the witch Queen reveals
that this is the first time that Dorothy
has returned to the witch's Forest after
leaving on her own a long time ago and
because of the immense importance of
this moment and the world breaking
consequences of the ongoing final battle
against Lucius the witch Queen agrees to
help bring us the back in the next scene
we see a giant mirror-like gate on one
end of a large room and a whole bunch of
witches are spread around the room in a
circle including of course the three
strongest witches all the witches will
now focus in on fineral's Magic in order
to amplify it many times over allowing
him to invoke a super compound magic
spell called door war of Destiny finroll
is a bit concerned that he is about to
be like sacrificed or something but
Dorothy tells him to just think of the
person he wants to meet and he will meet
them in the final panels of the chapter
we see Asta back at Hino country he is
putting on his black Bull's robe and
preparing to depart Asta is finally back
in the story and he knows that the time
to return to the Clover Kingdom has come
with the help of funeral spatial magic
and the amplifying power of dozens of
the world's strongest witches a magic
portal is about to be opened all the way
to Hino Country and this will allow ASA
to make it back in time for the final
battle man it's been a while since we've
gotten to see Asta and I'm glad that he
is finally back we all know that he is
crucial for this final battle and
Tabitha has done a good job of reminding
us of that fact over and over again
including the last few chapters but this
makes me wonder why is Oz does so
special I mean of course he's the
protagonist of the manga so we as manga
readers know that he is special but why
is he so special within the story itself
why is he special in the diegetic sense
why is Asta literally some sort of
glitch in The Matrix and seemingly
lucius's single biggest weakness is it
all just a huge Cosmic coincidence well
if you've been following this Channel
and my Black Clover content you know
that I've had a theory for quite a while
I believe all of this is leading up to
one big reveal and that is that asta's
existence is not unnaturally occurring
phenomenon I believe that Asta was
artificially created as the Ultimate
Weapon that would eventually defeat
Lucius I think Asta was born to be the
anti-magic using God killer and if this
is true then who could have created him
and how my theory is that Julius is
asta's father and that he created us in
order to stop lucius's master plan
because they share the same body Julius
knew that Lucius was planning to take
over the world for literally decades and
so he worked in secret together with
lichita to create someone who could be
immune to lucius's time magic power
someone whose future can't be seen and
who is therefore everyone's best hope of
defeating Lucius Asta was born as an
anomaly the only human without any magic
whatsoever and that was no coincidence
lichita's unique absorption power
combined with the power of Julius
allowed Asta to be born the way he was
in fact Julius may also be the father of
liebe the only devil without magic power
who eventually developed the overpowered
ability known as anti-magic my theory is
that the time devil asteroth was
involved in the creation of both Asta
and liebe and in fact asteroth's soul
may have been split in into two by
Julius and the two halves became Asta
and liebe time magic itself was kept
inside of julius's own body that's why
Lucius can still use it but in its place
we witnessed the development of
anti-magic the one ability that is
resistant to time magic what do you guys
think of this is the fact that Asta is a
glitch in The Matrix and lucius's
ultimate weakness just a really big
coincidence or is it possible that Asta
was literally created for the specific
purpose of becoming the god killer who
will defeat Lucius could liebe also be a
similar creation is the time that will
astroth involved in all of this don't
forget to leave your feedback down in
the comments below I can't wait to see
what happens in the next chapter if you
guys enjoy our black lower content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now and
if you watch my videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
big favor and subscribe right now and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications all over 50 percent of
you guys who watch my videos are not
subscribed subscribing is free and it
would help me out a lot so please do it
right now as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys